let's start off with segment a B so
that's point a this is point B right
over here and let's set up a
perpendicular bisector of this segment
so it will believe both perpendicular
and it will split the segment in two so
this we could call that line L that's
going to be a perpendicular it's a
perpendicular bisector so it's going to
be it'll intersect at a 90 degree angle
and it bisects it this length and this
length are equal and we could even set
let's call this point right over here
let's call that M maybe M 4 midpoint
what I want to prove first in this video
is that if we pick an arbitrary point on
this line that is a perpendicular
bisector of a B then that arbitrary
point will be an equal distant from a or
the distance from that point to a will
be the same as that distance to the
point is the same as that this same is
the distance from that point to B so let
me pick an arbitrary point on this
perpendicular bisector so let's call it
let's call that arbitrary Point C and so
you can imagine we like to draw a
triangle so let's draw a triangle where
we draw a line from C to a and then
another one from C to B and essentially
if we can prove that C a is equal to C B
then we've proven what we want to prove
that C is an equal distance from A as it
is from B well there's a couple of
interesting things we see here we know
that am is equal to Mb and we also know
that CM is equal to itself obviously any
segment is going to be equal to itself
and we know if this is a right angle
this is also a right angle this line is
a perpendicular bisector of a B and so
we have two right triangles and if you
don't even have to worry about that the
right triangles if you look at triangle
AMC you have this side is congruent to
the corresponding side on triangle B MC
then you have an angle in between that
corresponds to this angle over here
angle AMC corresponds to angle B MC and
they're both 90 degrees so they are
congruent and then you have the side MC
that's on both triangles and those those
are congruent so we can just use SAS
side-angle-side congruence
side-angle-side congruence so we can
write that triangle
a.m.c AMC is congruent congruent to
triangle BMC to triangle BMC by
side-angle-side congruence
side-angle-side congruence and so if
though they are congruent then all of
the corresponding sides are congruent
and AC corresponds to BC so these two
things must be congruent this length
must be the same as this length right
over there and so we've proven what we
want to prove this arbitrary point C
that sits on the perpendicular bisector
of a B is equidistant from both a and B
and I could have known that if I drew my
C over here or here I would have made
the exact same argument so any seed that
sits on this line so that's fair enough
so let me just write it so this means
that AC is equal to is equal to BC now
let's go the other way around let's say
we find some point that is equidistant
from a and B let's prove that it has to
sit on the perpendicular bisector so
let's do this again so I'll draw it like
this so this is my a this is my B and
let's draw out some point we'll call it
C again so let's say that C right over
here now maybe I'll draw see right down
here so this is C and we're going to
start with the assumption that C is
equidistant from a and B so C a is going
to be equal to C B this is what we're
going to start off with this is going to
be our assumption and what we want to
prove is is that C sits on the
perpendicular bisector of the
perpendicular bisector of a B so we've
drawn a triangle here and we've done
this before we can always drop an
altitude from this side of the triangle
right over here so we can set up a line
right over here let me draw it like this
so let's call let's let's just drop an
altitude right over here I'll really not
dropping it we're kind of lifting an
altitude in this case but if you rotated
this around so that the triangle look
like this so that the triangle looked
like this so that this was
so this was B this is a and that C was
up here you would really be dropping
this altitude and so you can construct
this line so it is a it is adding a
right angle with a B and let me call
this the point at which it intersects M
so to prove that C lies on the
perpendicular bisector we really have to
show that C M is a segment on the
perpendicular bisector and the way we've
constructed it it is already
perpendicular we really just have to
show that it bisects a B so what we have
right over here we have two right angles
if this is a right angle here this one
clearly has to be the way we constructed
it it's it's at a right angle and then
we know that we know that cm is going to
be equal to we know that cm is going to
be equal to is going to be equal to
itself and so we know by this is a right
angle we have a leg and we have a
hypotenuse we know by the rsh postulate
rsh postulate rsh we have a right angle
we have one corresponding leg that's
congruent to the other corresponding leg
on the other triangle we have a
hypotenuse that's congruent to the other
hypotenuse so that means that our two
triangles are congruent so triangle a cm
is congruent to triangle B cm by the RS
h postulate well if they're congruent
then the corresponding sides are going
to be congruent so that means that am so
that tells us that a M must be equal to
BM because they're their corresponding
sides so this side right over here is
going to be congruent to that side so
this really is bisecting a B so this
line MC really is on the perpendicular
bisector it really is part of the
perpendicular bisector and the whole
reason why we're doing this is now we
can do some interesting things with
perpendicular bisectors and points that
are equidistant from points and do them
with triangles so this was a neat you
know just to review we found hey if any
points it's on a perpendicular bisector
of a segment it's equidistant from the
endpoints of a segment and we went the
other way if any point is equidistant
from the endpoints of a segment it's it
on the perpendicular bisector of that
segment so let's apply those ideas to a
triangle down so let me draw myself an
arbitrary triangle I'll try to draw it
fairly large so let's say that's a
triangle of some kind
let me give ourselves some labels to
this triangle it's a point a point B and
Point C you could call this triangle ABC
now let me just construct the
perpendicular bisector of segment a B so
it's going to bisect it so this distance
is going to be equal to this distance
and it's going to be perpendicular so it
looks something like that and it will be
it will be perpendicular this a little
different because I the way I've drawn
this triangle it's it's get it's making
us get close to a special case which we
will actually talk about in the next
video let me draw this triangle a little
bit differently let me draw it a little
bit every time line okay and then let me
draw it let me okay this one might be a
little bit better and we'll see what
special case I was referring to so let's
this is going to be a this is going to
be B this is going to be C now let me
take this point right over here which is
the midpoint of a and B and draw a / to
draw the perpendicular bisector so the
perpendicular bisector might look
something like that might look something
like that and I don't want it to make it
necessarily intersect and C because
that's not necessarily going to be the
case but this is going to be a 90 degree
angle and this length is equal to that
length and let me take let me do the
same thing for segment AC right over
here let me take its midpoint which if I
just roughly draw it looks like it's
right over there and then let me draw
its perpendicular bisector so it would
look something like this it would look
something like this so this length right
over here is equal to that length and we
see that they intersect at some point
let's call that point just for fun let's
call that point O and other some
interesting properties of point O we
know that since o sits on a B's
perpendicular bisector we know that the
distance from o to B is going to be the
same as a
from o to a that's what we proved in
this first little proof over here so we
know we know that o a is going to be
equal to OB well that's kind of neat but
we also know that because it's the
intersection of this green perpendicular
bisector and this yellow perpendicular
bisector we also know because it sits on
the perpendicular bisector of of of a a
see that it's equidistant from a as it
is to see so we know that Oh a is equal
to OC now this is interesting
Oh a is equal to OB Oh a is also equal
to OC so OC and OB have to be the same
thing as well so we also know that OC
must be equal to must be equal to OB OC
must be equal to OB well if a point is
equal sorry if a point is equidistant
from two other points that sit on either
end of a segment then that point must
sit on the perpendicular bisector of
that segment that's that second proof
that we did right over here so it must
sit on the perpendicular bisector of BC
so if I draw the perpendicular bisector
right over there then it will look it
will this definitely lies on DC's
perpendicular perpendicular bisector and
what's neat about the simple little
proof that we've set up in this video is
if we've shown that there's a unique
point in this triangle that is
equidistant from all of the vertices of
the triangle and it sits on the
perpendicular bisectors of the three
sides or another way to think of it
we've shown that the perpendicular
bisectors of the three sides intersect
at a unique point that is equidistant
from the vertices and this unique point
on a triangle has a special name we call
Oh a circumcenter circumcenter circum
circumcenter and because o is
equidistant to the vertices so this
distance let me do this in a color I
haven't used before this distance right
over here
this distance right over here is equal
to that distance right over there is
equal to that distance over there if we
construct a circle that has a center at
O and whose radius is this orange
distance whose radius is any of these
distances over here we'll have a circle
that goes through all of the vertices of
B after all of the vertices of our
triangle centered at O so our circle
would look something like this my best
attempt to draw it and so what we've
constructed right here is one we've
shown that we can construct something
like this
but we call this thing a circumcircle
circumcircle
and this distance right here we call it
the circumradius circum radius and once
again we know we can construct it
because there is a point here and it is
centered at O now this circle because it
goes through the vertices of our
triangle all of the vertices of our
triangle we say that it is circumscribe
circumcising it circumscribed about the
triangle so we can say right over here
that the circle o the circumcircle o so
circle o circle o right over here is
circumscribed circum described about
about triangle ABC which just means that
all three vertices lie on the circle and
the circle as it's every point is the
circum radius away from this
circumcenter